hey everybody welcome to visual studio
toolbox i'm your host leslie richardson
and today
i am joined by mika dumont who is a pm
on the.net team
how's it going mika good how's it going
leslie
it's going all right so speaking of
productivity that's what we're going to
be talking about right
yeah and um leslie since
uh you work on the debugger i thought
that i can go ahead
and start with our debugger refactoring
and so i'm going to go ahead and share
my screen
and there we go and so
the uh very first feature that i wanted
to show
again um this is brand new it's a
refactoring where you can
pin properties programmatically in your
code
by adding this debugger display
attribute
oh i love that attribute yeah it's
pretty awesome
and uh this will also automatically
generate a
method and um it's default
return is two string but if i want i can
actually
go ahead and have it return
uh the first element of an array
i'm gonna go ahead and save that and
already set my
breakpoint over here and i can just
debug this test real quick just to show
you what this feature does
so you already get 50 bonus points for
me for
starting your demo out with the bugger
display or just anything debugger
related so
congratulations yeah
yeah so here you can see that the first
value
is a zero index of the array which is
this little dog emoji
and so without having to go ahead and
manually you know pin these properties
um
using the divider ui i can just you know
programmatically do that
in my code that's cool yeah refactoring
that's neat yeah because now you can do
it you can have it both ways so if you
like
debugger display as an attribute and you
want to get crazy complex with it then
you can use that except now you can
access that feature a lot better it
seems
like i love that you made that a
refactoring option
and uh conversely if you like debugging
and you just like playing around in the
watch window then you can use that pen
icon that
mika just explored yeah exactly
and um the next one i since we're here
um you might notice that we have
a couple of these regular string
literals and
it's boy i don't know leslie yeah it's
kind of hard to persist this is saying
right
yeah how do you even know what to type
in for that
so exactly so we actually have a
refactoring now where you can actually
convert this to a verbatim string
so it makes it a bit more legible and
uh if i want i can also convert it back
to
a regular string so that's just a
neat new refactoring that we just added
that's really nice
yeah cause sometimes you know i might
add an extra n or something or an extra
backslash and i don't know if it's
actually gonna work
until i print it out or it goes wherever
the string needs to be
yeah so now you can just easily see what
you're typing and just
switch around instead of having to
process it every time you
go past that line good grief yeah
exactly yeah
and um while we're here i do want to
show you this one too
so i'm going to uncomment this so the
keyboard shortcut for
uh toggle block comments is ctrl shift
forward slash
and uh just want to point that out and
so here you might notice that i'm
getting an
error and if i hover over this air quick
and post letting me know that
um this expression cannot be implicitly
cast
and uh luckily we have a code fix
to add an explicit cast
yay that's so exciting i hate that yeah
yeah and so yeah so like i don't know if
you're like familiar with like just
having to like
go and like hover over to learn what the
type was declared as um this will just
go ahead and you know serve that right
up uh for you
that's that's what's so cool about
refactoring tips like that it's just
like they're
small but mighty quality of life
improvements to me that just
make my life easier yeah it's just the
little things you know
what else and i do want to point out um
you know hopefully
you're pretty familiar or the audience
is pretty familiar with
uh this you know light bulb uh
icon and so this light bulb represents
quick actions
and quick actions allows you to easily
refactor generate or modify code with a
single action
and i can go ahead and invoke this by
either selecting the light bulb icon or
i can just you know type control period
or alt enter
and it'll also invoke it and this you
know
latest refactoring that we have is
converting a switch statement to the new
c sharp 8 switch expression
and so this will just go ahead and you
know
provide a more look at that
yeah it's like magic exactly and so this
will just go ahead and
you know provide a more concise syntax
without having to like write out the
returns um in each case
right sweet saves you a lot of trouble
yeah and it also just helps you learn
about you know new c-sharp language
features too
so it's pretty cool and uh
i don't know if you notice all of these
xml comments over here
yeah always fun to write whenever you
need to
explain what a given class or method
does yeah and
um we actually now have a quick info
style support for xml comments so
if i go ahead and hover over this class
you will notice
that quick info will display italics
bullets
numbers bolds and uh clickable link
so it's really cool
and uh well i'm talking about xml
comments um
over here you can see that this doll
card is inherited from this animal card
class
and let's see if
i go ahead and add this
inherit doc tag um
you will see that um dog card now will
inherit
from the you know from it's like from
different base classes or interfaces
just depends like where you want to add
that inherent doc tag
and so this just eliminates you know the
unwanted copying and pasting of
duplicate
xml comments and it will automatically
keep your xml comments synchronized
so yeah that's pretty sweet so before
that
keyword existed uh you'd have to
remember to go back to like the base
class and
update accordingly yeah you would just
have to like copy and paste them in here
if you want to
remember yeah yikes yeah
time zone yeah i'm trying to think what
else i have that i can show you
um oh so over
here let's see oh here's a good one
and notice how i have comments just to
remind me of all that
too demo and big bold letters
yeah exactly totally natural don't worry
about it
yeah um so so anyways yeah this ternary
condition
uh it's you know terraria conditions can
be great but sometimes
at the end of editing some logic you
realize things could be
a bit simpler there's a lot going on
here you know
yeah and uh i always have i feel like i
always have to go on stack overflow and
look up what does this mean again like
what part is the l statement
which part is this yeah yeah exactly and
you know we just want to make things you
know um
easier to read and we just want our code
to just be easily read and consume
so we do have this uh
cofix to simplify conditional
expressions
and that just makes it so annoying yeah
like can you believe that they both
meant the same thing right
yeah like you mean i just spent five
minutes deciphering this just to
find out yeah like did your brain hurt a
little bit
like it's 2 am i'm looking at this card
so those are just some of the latest
code fixes and refactorings and
next i want to show some tooling
improvements
this one's actually my favorite one uh
so this is um
there's like tons of excitement from the
community about this one
and um so we pretty much we added
intellisense inside daytime and time
span
literal strings so in this piece of code
i'm
taking a date time and i'm calling to
string on it
and if i start typing uh a daytime
stream literal you will notice yeah i'm
getting suggestions
yeah these are completion options and
explanations
as to what what each of these characters
mean
so you can see here this is what it
looks like so it's pretty
crazy it's snazzy yeah and
while i am talking about you know
intellisense completions
and oh let me missing a quiche um i do
want to point out you know
um we also have intellisense completion
for regular expressions
so i can go ahead and just show you that
real quick
let's see so here i'm just going to
write a regular expression
and so notice how i get
yeah low and behold uh notice completion
options
and explanations as to what each of
these characters mean
uh what's really cool too is that i also
uh get a tool tip so quick info will
actually let me know if i'm
missing like i'm missing my closing
parenthesis
so it's pretty smart it's really awesome
this seriously would have been so useful
to me a couple months ago when i was
writing a calendar app
and writing date formats everywhere and
trying to look up what
format i need to be using
[Music]
yeah and um yes i actually remember that
calendar app
that you should right
five years ago in march i know it feels
like forever ago it's crazy yeah
um but yeah um so these are just nice
inline experiences that we offer instead
of having to
you know go to the browser and learn how
all of this works
so great yeah let's see i have
another uh another tool tip so
um we've had you know changed signature
for a long time
where you can go ahead and you know
reorder parameters or remove parameters
uh but we just recently added the
capability to
add a parameter so here i can go ahead
and add the type as well as
the parameter name i can also
make this required or optional with a
default value
and i can decide what i want to inject
into the
call site and i can also
introduce you know to do variables so
this will basically put a to do in my
code so i can like visit those errors
and go through each call site
independently and decide what needs to
be passed
that's awesome yeah and for um
optional parameters i can also uh choose
to
um you know i can choose to omit the
call site completely so it's
pretty cool and once you select okay you
will see
a preview of the new uh method signature
and you will see that this is the new
parameter so
it's pretty awesome this is like one of
our highest requests from
from the community so we're really
excited to get this one out
that's really great so i especially like
the adding the to-do's
just automatically instead of having to
remember where you called this function
everywhere
that's pretty nice yeah it's a it's a
pretty awesome new feature
um let's see oh i have another one real
quick too i want to show
so um so we added file header support
and this allows you to add file headers
to existing
uh you know files within a project or a
solution
using an editor config uh so this is an
editor config file for those of you that
don't know
it's a single file that documents all of
your code style
or code quality options that lives at
the root of your repository
and can be managed by regular source
control and shared across your entire
team
uh so you can think of it as a universal
way of encoding
enforcing code style code quality
preferences across your team
yeah so it's pretty cool and so here we
have this file header template um and
you would just have to set the value to
equal the file header that you
text that you would like to get applied
to your c-sharp or visual basic files
this currently only works for c-sharp
and visual basic
and if you go to the first line of
your file you can go ahead and select
this bottle header so yeah
it's pretty awesome and not only that i
just want to point out
a lot of our code fixes um
and even and for the file header feature
as well you can really
actually apply all of these fixers to
your entire document project or solution
so you can scope it however you'd like
so if i want
i can add this file header across my
project
yeah and it will open this preview
changes window where i can just
you know select or deselect uh which you
know files i want this to apply to
and go ahead and do that and
you can see that it was added and if i
go to other classes you can see that was
added too so it's pretty cool it's
pretty cool
yeah yeah i'm going to add emojis to all
my file headers from here on out too
yeah that's the only way to write file
headers yeah
really though spice it up a bit yeah
so i mean it seems like there's a lot
you can do in that edit
editor config window in in general right
so like
how can people learn more about what
they can and can't do in there
specifically
yeah we uh well we have like
documentation that i can always
point users to we also have for
you know all the different code style
options
um you can go to code style
you can just use ctrl q search over
there and here you can actually it's a
little bit easier to understand this ui
that we have and you can actually see
all the different
code style preferences that you want and
have it applied to your editor config
as well that's neat yeah and so if you
want you can
do tabs versus spaces
yeah so you can just you know enforce
these code style and code quality
options across your team so if you're
like really adamant about tabs you can
just
sneak that word in there and then just
push your code everything will just
have to use tabs that's like the dream
of being a manager right
you get to assert your belief of
yeah yeah and uh yeah and so we're doing
a lot of work with this too
so stay tuned uh with the editor config
so yeah exciting stuff happening with
that
yeah it is and so we have oh yeah go on
oh i'm just gonna say speaking of
exciting things coming
i mean it feels like i look away for
five minutes and all of a sudden there's
like 20 new cool
refactoring items added so
what's coming soon in productivity land
yeah okay let me let me show you
okay so let's see
so some new features that are coming uh
the first one i can show
is so here we have um
here let's see which one should i show
first um okay i can show this one
so there's now a uh refactoring that
introduces the new
c-sharp nine pattern combinators
so over here i just you know place my
cursor and
select um let's see use pattern matching
it will go ahead and use those pattern
matching combinators
yeah so that's like a new uh c sharp
nine feature or the pattern matching
combinator so it's really exciting
and yeah and uh another one that we
recently just added so these are all
um coming in 16.8 preview one
so everyone who wants to learn more
about it can just check out the release
notes as well
and yeah and so uh this one here
um so this is we now have like a
suppression operator warning and code
fix
and this helps you easily identify and
fix suppression operators that
have no effect so in this case let's say
in this case i wanted to express that
something isn't
type string um and so this
operator here makes sense but it it's
not actually um
checking for that so i
we have a code fix where you can either
remove the operator completely um or
if you want to actually check it you can
use the is not that's if you're checking
it it's not a type string
yeah that's great yeah so that's like a
new one that we just came out with
and let's see what else do i have here
we have another one where you can remove
the
in keyword uh where the argument should
be passed by reference
so that's just also like a quick little
fix too
and trying to think what else oh we have
another one let's say
here i can do it
um let's say i want to just
go ahead and let's see
um okay let's say i want to just create
a
abstract method
um let's see so over here you'll just
notice
that i have an error and that's because
my class isn't
abstract so we have a quick fix to also
make a class
abstract and you can see here that i
wasn't there before
no oh wow yeah that just seems something
that would
naturally be be there so i'm glad that's
there yeah
um yeah so those are uh some of yeah so
those are the latest code fixes ring
factorings coming to
16.8 preview one
that is very exciting like serious
there's
not a bad one in the bunch from what i
could tell
like all these seems super beneficial to
anybody who's just
coding away no matter what you're
working on which is the cool part about
productivity
tools like that yeah it's really awesome
and
i don't know if we have time but i can
also just show a couple in the solution
explorer that was recently added that
are just really cool
okay yeah um so here um
i have a test project and it's just for
demo purposes i'm gonna delete
um this reference so i'm referencing my
project here
and so so now i'm not referencing
anything
and if i want to go ahead and add a
project reference
you know i would have to go to add and
then add the project reference
but we just added the ability to
uh drag and drop the project you'd like
to
reference and voila notice how this
project reference was added and
it was also added underneath the
dependencies node within the solution
explorer
great so no need to worry about syntax
typos
any of that yeah just you can just drag
and drop
yeah and um and another last thing about
with the solution explorer that i wanted
to point out is uh
we added the capability of copying
pasting and dragging files from file
explorer to solution explorer
so instead of having to um
right click and add an existing item
and you know we you then have to like we
navigate to where your path already is
you can now simply
drag and draw this file and it will get
copied
right to your source so it's pretty
awesome
that is so great yeah it's really cool
gosh are those features available in uh
16 8 or are they they're already
available
yeah they're out now okay yeah how
exciting
yeah it's pretty exciting stuff
let's see yeah and i think that's um all
i have
today but yeah definitely uh check out
the release notes
and um also all of our code fixes during
factorings
are at ak dot ms4 refactor code and so
um yeah that's where you can just learn
about all these new
tips and tricks and you can be the
coolest person on your team that
everyone goes to
like learn about that yeah
just just sit in your office chair like
yeah so
did you know you can now drag and drop
into the solution file
i mean i figured everybody knew but just
in case you didn't
here you go well that's really exciting
i'm gonna have to make a trip to that
website too because
i keep missing out on all these
wonderful refactorings that i should
totally be taking advantage of
as it sets up should everybody yeah
so thanks for being here mika that was
super informative
i feel super charged in my experience
definitely
thanks and yeah and again if you want to
learn more check out
the website that mika just mentioned
aka.mslash
refactor code awesome yeah
sweet and with that happy coding